Chỉn Hĩnh Ngay An và Đông Bộ Bị Tóm, cùng với một trong bệnh bị chính ký lâu gàn chất cấm.
Lực lượng chức năng thị của Hà Đội, vừa phát thành công đường dây và truyền trất cấm từ nước về Việt Nam,
tu dưới một trong bệnh bị chính ký lâu gàn chất cấm tổ hợp.
Các lối tật luyên gàn trong vua an đã bị gắt sử, bao gục nguyên hồ hùng,
xin nămu nghìn chi chăm tri me ba, in thành, ngay An, thà và cường xin nămu nghìn chi chăm tri me tư, tư nguang,
muyên khăm nọc xin nămu nghìn chi chăm tà mít tư, hải phòng.
Vào điên vức thẳng xin nămu nghìn chi chăm tri me sấu, hà nội, chức đó,
lực lượng chức năng ký nàynh kìm chà lâu hàng từ nước về Việt Nam,
có xin bay được bay.
Lâu hàng ngày gồm hai phát lát, với sau mấy kịt chứ lọn nó kẹp trái cây,
có tổng gối lượng là sau chăm bà bị bệnh ký lâu gàn.
Có kìm chà xưa bộ, lực lượng không ăn phát hiện có 1 mi sấu kịt hàng chứ góc về nán như là chất cấm.
Nhân định đây là một lượng dây vận chuyển chất cấm có khuy mối lớn,
lãnh đạo không ăn hà nội chỉ đạo các đần việc của hiệu đều tra làm gió vụ việc,
bằng các tiện phát nghiệp vụ, tổ công tác đã bất sử thành công các lỗi tượng chính kể chúng đến nhận hàng,
tại khu vực quận bắt tư liêm vòng ngày 1 bú tân xấu.
Chúng coa chình mật phục, tổ công tác thất hiện,
mỗi hộ hùng đăng lượng cách khu vực xa nhận hàng khoảng 20 mết,
và có số hiệu giám sát việc bốc sét.
Hùng bị bất sữ này sau đó, tại các quán công an,
không khai nhận việc bân chuyển thế trong một người đa nông,
đây là lần thứ ba hùng thân ra bân chuyển,
với mức tủ lào thứ 255 mết tư trực đồng mối lần.
Lửa tự hà văn khương, người đứt sâu nhiệm vụ giám sát việc sâu nhận hàng,
không khai rằng anh ta được vụ người đa nông tên là khuy ở nghe ăn,
thưa để theo dõi về chup anh có chính bốc xét hàng,
khi thương đăng theo dõi thì bị công an bắt sữ,
tiếp tục mở giống đều tra,
lực lượng chức năng phát hiện có một gình bú trong bỗn mì hộp nước cách tạo xong sống mì két hàng.
Bình chính khi lâu gà, đây 1 năm tần sau,
tổ cũng thác tại khận hà đông,
bất sức định rất tháng của bối 1 ôt tổ và 2 định thại gì đâu.
Tháng khai nhận nắm mối chức cấm của mạng giá hội tay này gồang,
tư một người không gió sang tính, tháng cũng thân nhận,
đã nhận được yêu cầu để khu vực phủ hương,
khận hà đông để nhận bà nghiên nế túc lắc,
trong đó ba chức điên là cửa tháng,
có lạc là cửa người khác,
cùng này,
tại khu vực gã tư cầu liên,
phận lông biên,
được lượng chức năng bắt sử dưới tượng miếng khác nông.
Nó khai nhận được một người đa nông ở khá buổi chia thê nhận chất
khẩm với số tiện 2 mi trộ đông.
Thế 1 môi tháng 6,
tông ăn thành của hà nội đã ra quyết định khởi tổ vua an hình sự,
lời vi hồng có các đồng phạm về hành vi,
mua bán phần chuyển trái khác chức thấm,
các lối tượng đã bị tạm giữ trong sự hục hành cấp,
để phục bụng cấm tắc điều tra.